bienvenidos a la serie de france 24 hoy
dedicada al aniversario de la explosión
del 4 de agosto de 2020 en beirut la
capital de líbano 2.700 toneladas de
nitrato de amonio estallaron en el
puerto provocando la destrucción de la
ciudad más de 200 muertos miles de
heridos y pérdidas calculadas en miles
de millones de dólares una presunta
negligencia investigada por la justicia
distintos documentos revelaron que las
autoridades sabían que estas sustancias
explosivas estaban almacenadas de forma
inadecuada empezamos este recorrido con
las demandas de justicia de las familias
las autoridades prometieron que en cinco
días se iban a esclarecer los hechos un
año después la investigación sigue sin
avanzar y organismos como amnistía
internacional han denunciado el bloqueo
de las autoridades además de la
resistencia de éstas al levantar la
inmunidad a los políticos procesados
mari y su familia comparten el dolor con
las otras familias que vinieron a
amenazar la memoria de sahar y de sus
ocho compañeros que murieron en la
explosión del puerto de beirut tenía 27
años ya había conseguido ser una de las
pocas mujeres paramédico en esta unidad
de bomberos la primera y única que
acudió al puerto
de cájar habría ido de todas maneras al
puerto le apasionaba su trabajo y no
reparaba en el peligro pero sin sus
superiores hubieran estado al tanto del
nitrato de amonio no lo habrían dejado
ir directamente a la muerte fue una
negligencia de los políticos como mariah
mariana perdió a su hermana la explosión
ahora capitanea la lucha de las familias
de las víctimas del puerto y su dolor le
animó a adjuntar al resto de las
familias y formar una asociación para
reclamar el derecho a una indemnización
ya que se haga una investigación justa
hemos luchado mucho para conseguir un
subsidio familiar para que las familias
de las víctimas puedan recibir la misma
asignación mensual que las familias de
militares fallecidos y ahora estamos
presionando para que los hijos
se han quedado huérfanos de padres
reciban una cuota escolar si pudiera
daría mi vida por la tuya saad eres mi
alma nunca te olvidaré y encontraré la
verdad para ti para mantener la memoria
viva los familiares de las víctimas se
han estado reuniendo cada día 4 de mes
para reclamar justicia y para que la
lucha que han iniciado no sea malo
solo siento rabia no es suficiente con
que nos paguen una compensación
económica el dinero no nos va a devolver
a nuestros seres queridos queremos saber
qué pasó queremos que los responsables
rindan cuentas
se cumple un año de la tragedia y
todavía no hay respuestas el coraje de
mujeres como amar y animaría animan a
muchos libaneses a unirse a seguir
reclamando justicia en un momento en el
que ni van a afrontar su peor crisis
económica política y social de los
últimos tiempos más allá del número de
fallecidos las víctimas tenían nombre y
apellidos centenares de familias
quedaron huérfanas en el siguiente
informe conoceremos de cerca la
imborrable huella que dejó la pérdida de
un joven trabajador portuario de 26 años
ambrosi es un barrio los suburbios del
sur de beirut
aquí es donde creció que hacen mawla
este empleado portuario perdió la vida
el 4 de agosto del 2020 cuando 2.700
toneladas de nitrato de amonio arrasaron
parte de la capital libanesa
su padre joseph recuerda aquella
terrible noche que pasó buscando a su
hijo
recorrimos los hospitales fui a ver a
los heridos estaba en las morgues
incluso examiné restos humanos para ver
si eran los restos de mi hijo no deseo
que nadie vea lo que dijo fue atendido
con salud la majada de su fe tenía 26
años el día de la tragedia a su madre
amalia sólo le quedan algunas fotos como
recuerdo
recuerdo a mi hijo cuando era pequeño lo
abrazaba le cantaba para que se durmiera
lo alimentaba espero que dios no los
perdone ahora sus fotos están colgadas
por todas partes sólo quedan las fotos
de qué sirve tener solo fotos
la investigación sobre este desastre
sigue abierta pero joseph teme que la
clase política esté obstruyendo el
proceso
de tal mala
a todo diputado o ministro cuyo nombre
se mencione deberá comparecer y su
inmunidad deberá ser levantada desde el
momento en que sea interrogado aparecerá
no como testigo sino como acusa al fayed
un año después de las explosiones y
usted y amable viven con el temor de
nunca saber verdaderamente qué pasó
aseguran que seguirán luchando a pesar
de todo para que se haga justicia para
su hijo y para las demás víctimas
pérdida del 80% del valor de la moneda
respecto al dólar 55% de la población
libanesa bajo el umbral de la pobreza
migración masiva consecuencia de la
guerra siria y una pandemia mundial son
algunas de las causas de la crisis
política social y económica de líbano a
las que se les sumó una explosión que
agravó la situación en el país afectando
la vida diaria de los ciudadanos de
beirut como demuestra el alza en el
precio del combustible
allí es chófer de taxi y desde el inicio
de la crisis de la gasolina pasa la
mitad de su jornada laboral haciendo
largas colas como esta
estoy esperando me toca esperar dos
veces al día pasó una hora o una hora y
media haciendo cola y a veces justo
cuando me toca ya no queda gasolina en
la estación
el combustible no solo es difícil de
encontrar sus precios también se han
disparado el estado al borde de la
quiebra debió reducir las subvenciones
para la compra de este producto
la bencina se importa hoy a un cambio de
3 mil 900 libras por dólar en lugar de
1500 una medida que preocupa al
ayer gasté 100.000 libras para llenar el
tanque en todo el día invertí 150.000
libras entonces solamente obtuve 50.000
libras de ganancia
hoy gaste 65 mil libras en combustible
lo que quiere decir que estoy perdiendo
dinero tengo cuatro niños que alimentar
y no sé cómo hacerlo
pero la escasez de combustible afecta
también otros aspectos de la vida
cotidiana
porque el problema no es solamente
llenar el tanque sino que es más grande
y va a afectar también las
hospitalizaciones el turismo y toda la
economía
todos los productos van a ser más caros
es debido al coste del transporte por
transportation porque para llevar un
producto de un lado a otro necesitamos
gasolina
esta crisis dentro de la crisis afecta
gravemente el estado de ánimo de la
población más que nunca los libaneses
temen que el país no pueda sobreponerse
de este golpe
tras la explosión la imagen recurrente
fue la de edificios destruidos no se
libró el patrimonio histórico un
centenar de inmuebles resultaron dañados
un año después los propietarios lamentan
la falta de ayudas estatales sin embargo
con el apoyo de distintas organizaciones
ya se han podido restaurar el 30 por
ciento de los edificios históricos
en el corazón de la capital libanesa el
prestigioso museo xurxo que es uno de
los edificios tradicionales más dañados
por las explosiones en el puerto de
beirut
después de un cierre forzado de dos años
poco a poco está volviendo a la vida
la destrucción fue enorme después de las
explosiones sobre todo en el edificio
principal en el sótano y en las obras de
arte recibimos el apoyo de la fundación
ad lift y del ministerio de cultura
francés lo que nos permitió realizar
renovaciones
cerca de un centenar de edificios
históricos resultaron dañados tras la
explosión en el puerto es el caso de
esta casa donde vive el padre y brian
cashman
a él le ayudaron asociaciones
especializadas en la restauración de
edificios patrimoniales y de que lo que
mi casa resultó muy afectada por las
explosiones del 4 de agosto estaba
inhabitable no había muros y el techo
dejaba pasar el agua
beirut reuters insider ha trabajado
durante tres meses para que en la medida
de lo posible la casa recupere su
carácter tradicional
las autoridades libanesas hicieron un
catastro de los daños unas semanas
después del desastre pero los
propietarios se quejan de que aún no han
recibido ninguna ayuda estatal
hace aproximadamente un año los
militares vinieron a inspeccionar las
instalaciones nos prometieron ayuda pero
fueron las asociaciones de la sociedad
civil las que realmente ayudaron con las
reparaciones
de perfil exacta del deseado
pero evites iniciatives y otras ongs han
logrado reparar el 30 por ciento de los
edificios históricos de beirut
el resto sigue destruido o inaccesible
en más de la mitad de los casos fueron
los propietarios quienes realizaron las
reparaciones en el resto fueron las
asociaciones que trabajaban en el
terreno incluida beirut here we touch
initiative las que hicieron el trabajo
para ello nos hemos asociado con otras
fundaciones la unesco por su parte
financió la rehabilitación de edificios
protegidos pertenecientes al estado
como cierre les dejamos con una
recopilación de imágenes de aquel
fatídico día en la historia del líbano
[Música]
siga todo el desarrollo sobre el
aniversario de la explosión que devastó
beirut y de la actualidad internacional
en france 24 y france24 puntocom
[Música]